welcome back to koi's comic corner i am
so excited to be here thank you thank
you thank you for the response to this
show please like subscribe leave a
comment this episode was actually a fan
suggestion of what to talk about they
said they wanted to know more about
doctor doom and here we are and remember
if you want to know more bite-sized
comic tidbits check out my tic toc i'm
making all of these all the time 15
seconds to three minutes or even a
minute there's lots of stuff over there
but in the meantime here long-ish form
where i can rant let's talk about doctor
doom because doctor doom seems to be the
source of a lot of conversation lately
so we're going to talk about why he's so
popular right now how i think he's going
to be introduced and why i don't think
that's in fantastic four gonna talk
about some fan casting ideas the ones i
hear rumbling and other ones that i
personally think would be rad why i
think that there are certain comics that
are going to influence it but not as
directly because i think the mcu is
going to take him in very different
directions and most of all what makes dr
doom one of if not the best marvel
villain of all time let's get into it
dr doom is the talk of the town doctor
doom is everywhere because we haven't
had doctor doom we've had the fantastic
four rumblings we've had john krasinski
show up in multiverse of madness and the
character i think a lot of people want
to see most post thanos is doctor doom i
think right now we've got kang as the
big underlying villain i think he's our
big emperor palpatine for phase four and
i think all these story lines are gonna
culminate in kang but i think right
alongside kang just as it is in the
comics we're gonna have doctor doom
currently in the comic books there's a
like a quantum entanglement between kang
and doctor doom in the current solo
title of doom kang appears and is
tethered to doom and i don't think that
is a coincidence for where the mcu is
going oftentimes there are hints at what
the movies are doing in the comic books
and right now that is a very big
storyline so first of all who is doctor
he is a badass evil dictator that runs
latveria and basically latveria is what
i think they were going to try to make
sokovia but they didn't have the rights
to doctor doom yet when you think about
the sokovia accords when you think about
a lot of the scenes not in new york in
the mcu there are people that are under
tyranny and doctor doom's interesting
because his people love him but he
abuses them he's one of our first very
very important political figures in the
mcu and the reason i don't think you
introduce him in fantastic four is
because you want the time to do him
justice you want him to feel like
someone bigger than just one corner of
the mcu when you meet him just like we
met thanos in a post credit scene for
the avengers you don't want it to feel
like oh this is going to be a captain
america bad guy if you introduce him in
fantastic four you're already
introducing four brand new characters to
some people or reintroducing them and
improving upon them plus you're gonna
have to establish why they haven't been
here all along and try to establish why
he is or isn't john krasinski depending
on how things go you're going to be
doing a lot in that movie with tone with
story with all those things so if you
haven't seen my fantastic four episode
of koi's comic corner i mentioned
annihilus i think annihilus is a very
streamlined villain you get the big boss
fight out of the way but you also build
the science and all those things within
the fantastic four doom
needs to be introduced i believe in
black panther too black panther 2 is
already going to be bringing in a lot of
political intrigue you've already got a
passing of the torch from one black
panther to another you've already got
the first character that we're gonna see
unfortunately in a very sad way
lose where we left off with the last
film and i think that passing the mantle
is gonna be very brutal but i think
they're gonna hand that in a very
political way i think there's going to
be an election i think there's going to
be a lot of discussion of what the
mantle means and i don't think it's a
coincidence that namor seems to be in
that movie namor is another almost
elected official he's the king of
atlantis he's also a very arrogant
leader that butts heads often with
doctor doom i personally would do the
less jokey version of the illuminati by
having a bit of a round table of leaders
that kind of help run the world it would
make sense to introduce our new black
panther
along with neymor as a villain and then
have doctor doom there running things
behind the scenes and also as someone
that the wakandans are aware of i think
we need to start sprinkling in latveria
and the more global scale of these
movies as we introduce more global
characters you may notice that the mcu
as it is right now is not as based in
new york city things bad happen in more
than just new york city and the
characters need to start reflecting that
so i think while they're doing that doom
needs to be doomed there needs to be a
sense of foreboding there needs to be a
sense of otherness and so much going on
so i think we're going to see him as
soon as potentially black panther 2.
whether he's in the movie or in a
post-credits scene how insane would a
post-credit scene be they somehow keep
this under wraps and then doom just like
clinches a fist with the mask like i
could see them doing that with this
character i also think as i said a
second ago introducing him in the movie
not only puts him in one vein but also
we don't have the time to really embrace
victor von doom now victor von doom is a
man who is as tech savvy as reed
richards who is as intelligent as reed
richards but he also has mysticism on
top of that so imagine someone with the
political power of black panther the
tech savvy of reed richards or if you
don't know reed that well perhaps iron
man picture an iron man black panther
combo but he's also got doctor strange
thrown in there this dude is terrifying
because he's all of those things but he
will destroy you like that and will and
often has done that with heroes and
civilians alike the only thing he cares
about is his kingdom the only thing he
cares about is his ego and the character
is fascinating because when he was first
introduced the way that kirby envisioned
him was someone that was so arrogant so
narcissistic that he wore a mask that
had a tiny scratch in his face and that
tiny imperfection kept him from the
perfection of others that little tiny
thing made him feel like he had to do
all of this and then later john byrne
one of my favorite artists one of my
favorite writers great guy decided to
make it more of a mangled totally
disheveled more traditional phantom of
the opera situation where like depending
on the continuity you're reading
homeboy's face is all messed up either
way his arrogance his ego his narcissism
fuels everything he does maliciously
he's afraid to show his face personally
i would love if he becomes doom scratchy
boy and you see that level of insanity
on a beautiful face all my casting
choices which we'll get to later and
some blokes but i think through the
course of maybe the sequel or as things
evolve maybe then you go full jarnburn
his face gets all messed up maybe it's
something reed does he often blames reed
and there's a beautiful parallel between
the ben grimm thing and dr doom as far
as things that happened to them that
made the monsters as caused by reed
richards so this is a guy who's got all
sorts of tech he's got doombots that
rival ultrons he's got mysticism that
rivals doctor strange's and there's a
really fun dynamic with his mother where
in a comic book i'm going to get to in a
bit he and doctor strange actually team
up to save his witch mother and that
leads to his whole bloodline and that
leads to the ancestry so you could also
incorporate agatha harkness so if this
goes like i want it to and they
introduce him as soon as black panther 2
we could potentially seen flashbacks in
agatha harkness we could see all of this
relate to maybe even helping scarlet
witch build up her magic back or if
she's gone he helped build that whole
scarlet witch tower there's so much that
doom relates to that i feel like we need
to start establishing them as a bigger
bad that takes over the whole universe
as ever i want to give you some of my
casting ideas uh some of these have been
floating around some of these are my own
i personally want someone that's vaguely
european which is a weird thing to say
but there's a there's a nest to latveria
that i really want them to capture i
would love if doom has an accent i would
love if he feels not like a guy could
run into in a burger king and i really
really really love the actor rufus
sewell and i feel like that dude does
not get enough credit he is the knight
in a night's tale the evil knight he's
also got this high castle show on amazon
he has this really really piercing gaze
that makes you feel like [ __ ] like he's
so so condescending with a glare and
he's the nicest guy in the world like
rufus is a great guy but the way he
looks at you is doom he's also got a
very commanding voice i need to feel
like i'm this big when i see doom
looking through that at me doom is death
embodied so you need to feel like death
is staring you in the eye so the actor's
eyes are very important so you feel the
depth of doom of death my next pick
would be michael shannon homeboy is a
force of nature there is almost no one
that when you're in a room with them
you're both like i want you to love me
and i'm also scared shitless this guy
could lead an entire community this guy
could run a country of latveria so i
want someone that is both charming in
his own way not to charm you into liking
him but to charm you into fearing him
and that to me is michael shannon plus
he's built like a brick [ __ ] house
dude's giant then i've got goron vishnik
this dude is from the er days he showed
up in the boys he's the cult leader from
the boys cult leader is actually a
perfect example of why he's one of my
picks he commands you with a glance and
he makes you doubt your own reality when
you lead a cult you've got to be so
captivating and so capable of getting
people to follow you that you don't know
why exactly you're shedding your family
and your choices and all these things
and i think goron has always been that
actor and he hasn't really had the time
to fight into a role of this size and i
think he'd do an exceptional job then
one of the ones that's been floated
around for quite some time that i
totally agree with definitely has that
european nest i could see him win the
doom mask and i've never seen him play a
full-on villain viggo mortensen i think
viggo mortensen post aragorn has been
doing all these great smaller roles like
captain fantastic and popping up and
things i would love to see him go the
other way and be terrifying i love him
as a great dad i love him as a leader i
love him as the guy you're rooting for i
want to fear him but i want to see him
as doom and i think he has the presence
he has the eyes he has the gays he has
the leadership give me that doom and my
final one for you is maybe the most
obvious when you think about a man
flipping a coin doom doesn't do that
when you think about a guy that's gonna
scare you shitless with just a can of
air also not do think about javier
bardem
as dr doom think about his drolling
speech pattern his ability to make
spaces and words that aren't there that
make you go like tell me more but i'm
scared i want dr doom to be someone that
pulls you in while you're running away
and very few villains in cinema have
done that quite like anton trigger's
haircut and javier bardem under it give
me javier bardem as doctor doom now
before i get into my comic
recommendations what do you think about
dr doom potentially showing up earlier
in black panther 2 before fantastic four
why do you think he's so interesting as
a villain and do you want to see any of
my fan casts as dr doom himself let's
get into some comics i got some
recommendations for you guys i think
might tie in directly to the story they
tell including doctor strange and doctor
doom triumph and torment this is a very
petite run you can really just absorb a
lot of dr doom in and very few issues
and it's dr strange and dr doom going to
save his mother it deals with witchcraft
it deals with mysticism it deals with
the arrogance of doom he's not generally
an anti-hero but at times he's become
that and i love the relationship between
these doctors so you can see why
everyone fears him and what that lineage
in witchcraft is and it's also just a
gorgeous run that catches up a lot of
doctor doom next up we've got secret
wars 2015. i would firstly recommend you
read the original secret wars the
original secret wars gives you the
symbiote saga with spider-man it's the
first time we see the venom suit it
brings in a lot of things i think are
coming in the inevitable secret wars
movie dr doom is also incredible in the
original secret wars but he's more of
well like literally there's a chessboard
scene and he's a pawn he's more of a
piece of the puzzle he's not the one
running the board and secret wars 2015
which i think is going to be a large
basis for the inevitable next avengers
movie i think the movie that people
wanted multiverse of madden to be is
going to be secret wars i think that's
coming i think it's going to be gigantic
and multiversal it's going to make end
game look quaint but it is largely a
doom story doom when there's an
incursion event which we did get
introduced to a multiverse of madness
the idea that these planets collide
causes these shards of planets and the
schism of reality that's an idea that's
strongly in secret wars 2015 and what
doom does with those is he patches
together the different planets in
different worlds and makes this thing
called battle world and battle world is
an entire world he runs much like
latveria and i think if we ever get a
giant crossover event doom and battle
world are going to be integral plus it's
beautifully illustrated the whole story
is fascinating it's jonathan hickman
it's illustrated by assad rabies if i
remember correctly and it's just a
stunner of a book came out in 2015
collected and trade pick it up last
recommendation is the current run of
doctor doom he has been around forever
he is a jack kirby stanley creation from
i want to say 1962. can't remember the
exact date but i know he's kirby and lee
and he's never had a solo title and
right now i think it started in 2019 we
have one that is so interesting because
it is it's illustrated by salvadoroka so
it's almost like a painted lines even
though it's comic book pencils and
coloring it's beautiful and it's
basically doom is blamed for something
he warned people about he warned people
that the satellite was going to
malfunction and crashed on earth killing
many people that reed actually helped
program and because he warned people
people start blaming doom they think he
sabotaged it they think he's the one
that caused this so doom in his
intelligence is blamed for his arrogance
and he was actually trying to help
people so it's a really fun story of
what it means for doom to want to save
people who he is as a man what his
morals are what his line in the sand is
with ethics and basically it allows you
to see the different sides of doom in a
very personal story and it ties into
kang which honestly i do think kang and
doom are going to be more integral in
the movies than they are necessarily in
the comics so check out doctor doom it's
called doctor doom check out secret wars
2015 and the original if you have time
and check out doctor strange and doctor
doom triumph and torment those my
recommendations those are my casting
choices those are my doctor doom ideas
this has been koi's comic corner i
appreciate you all so much the love i've
gotten for this show is like nothing
else remember check out my tick tock if
you want to see more short form comic
ideas and leave a comment below if
you've got any ideas for videos you want
to see greg you have anything to add no
no
18 minutes see you soon internet
[Music]
you